so I have major follow-up on last week's
a sort of Twitter battle that I had with
an activist and it got really ugly
including the attempt to get me fired
from my adjunct faculty position at
Boston College it involves Joe Rogan it
involves comedian Bill burr so the
backstory on this entire thing to catch
you up is that Amy Siskind last week or
maybe even a few days prior to that
don't remember exactly which day it
started tweeted something that I found
to be racist and sexist which is I will
not support white male candidates in the
Democratic primary unless you slept
through the midterms women were our most
successful candidate biggest Democratic
vote getters in history Obama oh wait
Hillary sixteen white male is not where
our party is at and is our least safe
option in 2020 I thought that this was
exactly the type of stuff that the left
should not engage in and I immediately
tweeted back to her quote isn't there
something not progressive about
preemptively dismissing a candidate
based on their race and gender I feel
like there's a word to describe that as
a progressive I won't be jumping on
board with that idea that was what we
knew last week so as a continuation of
this people started tweeting to me
saying hey Amy Siskind keeps tweeting
about this incident with you so I said
oh I've got to see that I'm not getting
those notifications so I go back to look
at Amy siskins post about this and I am
welcomed with the reality that she
blocked me you are blocked from
following Amy Siskind
and viewing Amy siskins tweets the next
day she called Boston College where I
adjunct taught last year and told them
to fire me since she had blocked me on
Twitter
she went to my personal Facebook page
remember I can't see her posts on
Twitter so because she blocked me she
goes to my personal Facebook to tell me
that she did this saying quote I called
Boston College to launch a complaint
that you should not be teaching young
minds but they said you do not teach
there I reported you anyway because you
should not be invited back may want to
reflect may want to update your Facebook
page to reflect reality now of course
that's true I'm adjunct faculty so if
I'm not teaching a semester I'm not
employed by Boston College that semester
I'm only employed when I'm actually
teaching what I would be super curious
about is what did she say when she
called right
she said something racist and sexist
saying she would on the basis of race
and gender preemptively dismiss a
candidate I say oh that's racist and
sexist and she calls Boston College to
say I should be fired what does she even
claim I did like what explanation do you
give to Boston College about why I
should be fired so I tweeted about this
on Twitter saying and then I said two
days ago Amy Siskind posted that she
won't vote for white or male candidates
in 2020 I pointed out this is racist and
sexist yesterday she blocked me on
Twitter today she called Boston College
demanding they not have me back as
adjunct faculty and as you can see this
generated a lot of activity 2,000
replies more than 5,000 retweets and
more than 18,000 likes and also Joe
Rogan discussed it with comedian Bill
burr on his program let's listen to just
a little bit of that pull up that per
tweet that i retweeted today the david
pakman retweet David Pakman is liberal
progressive guy this woman posts on
Twitter she would never vote for a man
or a white white man or a white person
white why is someone who's white or male
he says that's racist and sexist it is
so she blocks him on Twitter today she
called Boston College demanding that
they not have him back as adjunct
faculty it's crazy so this woman post
this and he points out that it's racist
and sexist so she blocks him and she
tries to get him fired okay that this is
why that whole thing is [ __ ] up
okay because he's acting like white
people exist on an even plane which is
what a lot of people try to do so it's
like he's not necessarily he's just
saying that what she's saying is racist
and sexist yes because she's determining
who she's gonna vote for based entire on
the race but there's other elements
involved like the level that white
people not saying all white people but
why
people have over people who are not
white forget about poor white people who
they [ __ ] over so you understand that
but they're both right but then like the
fact that she then takes it to the point
that because he had the audacity to have
a difference of an opinion that that's
the thing now and that now we're gonna
destroy you and you can't be on this
thing right so bill burr actually it
kind of goes off the rails but he
actually does make good points I just
think that their points may be for a
different conversation but that's that
so Phil isn't I'm not saying that this
is a huge problem on the left many
people are telling me siskins not even
really on the left she's a former Wall
Street person who voted for McCain Palin
in 2008 because Palin's a woman and
started an activist group with all
Hillary supporters so I don't know
whether she's strictly speaking on the
left or not but I'm against this type of
politics Pat I want to evaluate
candidates based on platform and issues
and ideas and that's it now I will say
if you have two candidates who are
equally qualified let's say two
candidates I agree with 94% of the time
I don't think it's bad to say hey you
know what I'm gonna vote for the one who
is from an underrepresented group that's
not what Amy Siskin suggested in her
tweet yeah there's a lots of flesh out
here I think it warrants a long-form
conversation maybe one that lasts two or
three hours and you might as well have
that conversation on a large platform so
maybe that's a possibility in the future
hey listen I'm accepting invites that's
for sure so that's the latest with it
and I don't know how much more we need
to say about it but that's the full
story as it exists as of right now